[Music]
so
let's snag one more speedrun game and of
course we will play the king's gambit
or the queen's gamut and here we go so
normally i play aggressively with white
but we've got a lot of questions about
the queen's gambit
so that's exactly what i'm going to play
i'm going to play the queen's gambit
which is not a
passive opening so okay so this is the
queen's gamut accepted
this is the queen's gamut accepted and
in the queen's game accepted there are
two fundamentally different ways of
playing
there is a more solid type of approach
that's connected
to e3 thank you sexy car gifting the
tier three
or there is a very aggressive
continuation which i
advocate to uh
most of the people watching which is of
course e4
there is also a misconception that e4 is
like the only move e4 is not the only
move it is not even the main move
but it is considered i think the most
testing move
currently okay so h6 is weird i mean
he's just letting us
take the pawn and now we have a great
position because every tempo matters
here
okay so e6 and
yeah so he's playing passively he's not
playing terribly
and just like in any other opening we
just need to develop our pieces there's
nothing that
there's nothing particularly crazy that
we have to do here so what should we do
yeah just knight f3 i mean knight c3
knight f3 it doesn't really matter we'll
start with knight c3
because it's a little bit more flexible
maybe we can get this knight to e2 yes
so knight you go
c5 and again we should follow our
instincts here
taking on c5 is clearly not a good idea
because it allows the queen trade
so the obvious move here and i don't see
a reason not to play it is just to push
d5
controlling more of the center and
creating a lot of tension
if he takes on d5 then we'll be able to
establish a very nice
knight on this outpost okay let's play
knight takes d5
and we've got a phenomenal position here
obviously we've got all these pieces
we've got a knight in the center just
give me give me one second guys
okay
yeah guys give me one second okay
actually let's make a move of my
uh routers the extender's coming loose
um so what should we do here let's make
the move and then i'll
i need like 10 seconds what's the move
here what should we do
and this is a very instructive moment in
my opinion because
a lot of players look at this move and
they say well
he's created a tension between the
knight so we have to react to that we
have to take on f6 we have to do
something about it we have to go queen
f3
but that is a false assumption black is
actually not threatening anything
because he wants to take on d5 yes
but then we'll just replace the knight
with a bishop and the bishop on d5 is
also good um
is he really threatening to take on e4
no
because we are outpacing him in
development
and taking on e4 is catastrophic because
that's going to open the e file
and we're going to put a rook on e1 and
we're just gonna check my name here so
we actually don't need to change our
play at all
you guys are trying to play queen f3 in
order to attack f7 but it's too early
for that
and the reason it's too early for that
is because
he's going to take on d5 and then he's
going to defend f7
and then it's going to be hard for us to
develop this knight to a natural square
and i'll show this after the game in
more detail
so actually we're just going to develop
as if nothing happened
because nothing did happen i'll be right
one second
all right and he's committed a blunder
so he has committed a blunder how do we
see this
you should totally spot the standoff
standoff standoff standoffs
the queens are in a standoff the king is
defending the queen
and we can distract the king by playing
the very classic move bishop takes f7
check
now ideally we would have to check that
after king takes f7 queen takes d8
he doesn't have bishop b4 check that is
a common idea
in response to this kind of tactic i
didn't actually do this because i saw
that the bishop is blocked by its own
pawn
so he blunders the queen we take it and
we're going to win
alternatively yeah the queen is a type 2
undefended piece so it's susceptible to
these kinds of tactics
and thank you ellis appreciate it and
thanks for your
support thank you thank you thank you
yeah king okay so here are signs now and
we are over twelve
yeah so this move e4 um
is is not the only movement the other
main move as i said is e3
now the benefit of e3
over e4 is that this keeps the d4 pawn
nicely protected this keeps the center
of better protected
um on the flip side it blocks
this bishop on c1 which is a drawback
but it's not a huge one
and there's a the other appeal of this
move
is that there is a trap that has existed
for
uh over 400 years which goes b5
now you have a pawn chain as you guys
know you should undermine the base of
the pawn chain a4
this pawn is undermined but he can try
to defend it with c6 if he tries to
defend it with a6
then you're going to run into a hanging
rook on a
so black can try c6 but if you try c6
then there's a b5
cb5 this diagonal is open
and queen f3 actually just wins a piece
or the rook
this is actually a very funny position
if you haven't seen this before
because it seems ludicrous that black
cannot defend the rook and yet he can't
so that has existed forever
and we got a donation and it's a twenty
dollar one from shando guardian thank
you so much man
the generosity today has not
stopped thanks man i really really
appreciate it
okay so yeah so e3
is is possible and generally speaking
black gives up the pawn
and goes e6 followed by c5 and it's a
combative position
but we decided to play e4 which is far
more
testing in particularly at like the
beginner intermediate level
now h6 is is just bad and
he just shows that our opponent doesn't
see
the urgency in the situation he just
sort of plays
kind of a move that covers the g5 score
but we didn't want to put anything on g5
anyway
and yeah that's way too passive and the
sort of the natural mover is e5 that's
the
main line that's the old main line
nowadays people have started to play
other stuff as well but e5 is still good
and it's a counter gambit because if you
take on e5
then black trades queens exposing
white's king which has lost its castling
rights
and remember black was up a pawn so
material is equal and white's king is
weak this is bad for white
and so instead white has to play the
move knight f3
black takes on d4 and white takes on c4
so white preserves the gambit
spirit of this line white is still down
upon
but we've developed two pieces black has
developed zero and we have pressure on
f7 so i'll put it this way
this line equalizes for black if he's
very very precise
but most people who've not studied the
theory
are going to get absolutely destroyed
here with black because black has to be
so so precise here
because he's got no develop and
that is why to repeat something i said
earlier sorry to
belabor the point here but when people
look at what magnus plays or what
aronian plays
and they try to model their repertoire
on
those people you often get very poor
results because
those people are able to violate the
rules thank you kind of pink jake
and to and they're able to do so because
they spend weeks and weeks and months
and years studying these lines
and for people who have less time to
devote to chess
you want to choose lines where even if
you forget the move order
if you forget your theory you're not
going to get swept off the board
all right so some people are asking
what happens if d5 well d5 is possible
but it's not particularly dangerous
because it closes up the center and
black can simply go
at f6 and uh you know black is fine you
can go bishop d6 and castle it's a
comfortable position
um okay so
knight f3 is the move here but our
opponent played h6 that's very passive
we take on c4 c6
knight c3 c5 d5 pushing this is all very
natural
knight f3 is the only i think
instructive position in this game
um a lot of you guys wanted to play
queen f3 and i i understand as i said i
understand
the impulse to play queen f3 two bucks
from archer assassin but
after knight d5 bishop d5 you're
basically playing for a one move threat
that's the problem here and this one
move thread is quite easy to pair
this is not bad for white this is
actually white is still much better but
i would be a little bit concerned here
even a move like when f6 could be
quite annoying even a move like queen f6
could be quentin because although
the end game is much better for white
you've ruined black's pawn structure
i'm not sure that this is the most that
white can squeeze
from this line if that makes sense which
is why
knight f3 i think preserves the tension
and gives white
better chance to win the game fast if 94
what do you guys think white does what
is the simplest
the most zen move here what is the move
in the spirit of knight f3
it is to castle good job it is to castle
because we want a rook anyone
putting the queen on e2 and i know this
is on some people's mind
is not as effective because of f5
defending the knight
we don't want our queen to be on the e
file we want our queen to be on the d
file staring off
the other queen the rook is the piece
that belongs on e1
and as they say in russian black black
will not even collect his bones
this is going to be a massacre so knight
c6 rookie one
and see the difference here is that the
queen is
free you've not saddled the queen
with the task of pinning the knight so
now the queen can go to h5
after this knight moves or you could
play the even simpler move bishop f4
trying to go for knight c7 and everybody
should see how much of a disaster this
is for black everything is falling apart
and we couldn't care less about the
extra pawn so
uh does queen d3 work for supporting the
center at which point
at this point well again i mean it's not
a bad move per se but we don't need to
play it
the point is we can not only
afford to sacrifice the spawn but this
is barely even a sack i wouldn't even
call this a sacrifice
because it's so overwhelming that taking
on e4 is just unthinkable
all right uh did i anticipate that he
could blunderscreen i mean i saw this
concept but i didn't think this would
happen
and of course he should have played king
e7 prolonging the game
what should we have done here what
should we have done here
this is um this is a
an instructive moment because what you
have to realize is that you don't want
to trade queens here
trading queens would prolong the game
although it's fine
and so if you ask yourself how can i
avoid the trade of queens
while not blundering the bishop you come
up with a very simple move bishop back
to d5
or queen b3 but i like bishop d5 why
keep the bishop on a vulnerable square
then you have many ideas like this then
you can castle and black
is i mean look at this king black is
completely busted you're just going to
continue your development and win easily
so that's basically that i mean once he
takes the game is over
yeah um bishop f7 k7 bishop d5 then
the media threat is to play knight e5
but that's not obligatory
okay if you did not f3 b4 knight c3
can you still take his d-pawn
well i assume you mean can you still
play d5 here and the answer is yes you
can play bishop takes d5 that's fine
and if knight f6 then you still have
this this idea so the answer is yes
um yeah so any questions about this game
okay looks like we're all pretty much
clear okay
let's go and we have black against
pierre tachago
let's do another car con that's what
we've been playing that's what we'll
continue to play and he goes e5 so
e5 is a weird move
it's not a horrible move it's actually
better than people make it out to be
and obviously this pawn is quite
annoying actually it's quite annoying
because it doesn't allow us to develop
our knight to f6 so
what should we do here to deal with this
pawn how should we deal with it
i have a feeling that some people are
thinking of moving the queen out
but remember the rule queens are not
particularly good
at picking off pawns like this and this
pawn can be very easily protected with
d4 so first we should play d6
to simply undermine this pawn okay so
he's taken
and the position is equal i mean if he
plays d4 he's not worse
but he's given us a check instead that's
already a bad move see
at this level if you simply follow the
rules
your opponents are he's going to do
something like queen e2 which is
in clear violation of opening rules i
mean he's blocking the development of
his own bishop
we've seen this move a million times now
how should we block this chuck because
we have this move we have this move
we have 97 well 97 we can rule out
because y blocked the development of the
bishop
and to figure out whether we should play
here or here
we should understand how we want to
develop
and what we want to develop first well
our immediate priority
noticing the queen of the king is going
to be to put a rook on e8 right
that will create potential dependent to
put a rook on the fastest way of doing
that is to castle short
and to castle sure we need to clear the
king side so bishop e7 is the move
knight f6 now we're probably not going
to get a chance to win a screen here if
he plays this carefully
but he is not playing this carefully do
we need to play h6 or should we castle
immediately
this is another instructive moment
we don't need to play h6 there's
absolutely no reason and i love that
people are actually seeing this i feel
like
that's some growth this knight is doing
absolutely nothing there's no reason to
be intimidated by it he's the sort of
guy who's going to play queen d3 here
and think
that he's intimidating us by attacking
on h7 but he's not
because queen d3 doesn't even threaten
anything but i have a feeling that he's
going to do something like this or
something like h4
okay knight c3 now
we obviously should go over key a
and now he's in big trouble because now
we are threatening simply to move the
bishop back to f8
and at the very least to win a knight
that might appear on e4
so beware these fake threats and how do
you know threats are fake
well go from first principles he's got
no pieces developed other than one
single night
that's not going to cut it that's not
something that you need to worry about
so what's the move here
yeah bishop f8 is correct and uh
94964 of course
and obviously on to d5 i'm not even
asking you guys to find these moves
these are very very straightforward
moves
and white is busted i mean he's got to
go here and then castle and but he's
just down tonight
okay queen d3 is even worse
now on the difference between
simplifying versus keeping pieces on the
board this is a great example
of when i think some people might
propose d take c4 to encourage the queen
trade and that would be a legitimate
decision
but in a situation like this it is very
very clear
that his king is in massive trouble so
there's no point in forcing the
simplification
when you can just go ahead and check
minimum basically right so you want to
use your judgment
when it comes to deciding between
simplifying and keeping pieces on the
board there's no algorithm to follow
you just have to make a judgment call
okay so bishop b2
now i know a lot of you are thinking
about this move but be very very careful
bishops can be blocked with pawns bishop
g4 is bad on account of f3
so instead we should focus on preventing
him from castling
there are several good ways of doing
that
but the move that just sticks a fork in
it
is bishop h3 we could have also moved
our queen to the side
uh pressuring the bishop okay so f3 we
should bring our brook back
yeah so this sticks a fork in it because
he's never going to be able to castle
past this bishop and if he tries to
bring his king to f2 which he might
goes bishop c okay rooks we can still go
bishop c5 developing with tempo
thank you sexy card to adrian 28 another
tier three
this man is unstoppable okay rook back
to h1
now let's be patient some of you guys
might notice this rook and say bishop g2
is winning it is
but this bishop is worth its weight in
gold i want to keep it on h3 because it
keeps his position paralyzed
when your opponent's position is
paralyzed like this
at some point you have to demonstrate
the patience
necessary to bring more pieces into the
game all we need
is maybe like one more rook into the
game so
we all we need to do is play a move like
knight d7 and that is going to greatly
ease
our task because it's going to give us
more pieces to work with
this knight can go out to e5 there's a
million ways to win this position
but yeah so
95 is good um there's a million times
that
there's a million ways to win this
position i i also like queen b6 or queen
e7
yeah queen e7 is a good move just piling
up on this bishop
it doesn't matter i mean everything is
winning here don't overthink this
this is just okay so this is the fastest
yeah and that's how you punish a move
like we need to
you just can't get away with this kind
of stuff all right and there's nothing i
did here
that was in in the least way creative or
um you know or
or or or had the gm title as a
prerequisite so
you know i hope that is clear a thousand
bits thank you
danny duncan's website you say and
what does that website show
okay so queenie to check is very very
bad obviously he should have played d4
and we would have played d5 and this
basically leads to like a
very symmetrical very boring position
and that the boring position
is equal and you have to be capable of
playing such positions
all right
yeah so i know it seems like like why
don't my opponents do that that's a
i get that that happens and uh that's
it's a frustrating thing but it will
happen
knight f3 knight f6 castle's knight 25
we literally did everything by the book
we put a rook on e8
we won his knight we stopped him from
castling
then we patiently brought a piece into
the game
we pinned him even further and we
delivered checkmate on the first attempt
okay so literally very very simple play
all right one more i'm feeling it guys
it's not even 2am yet
one more um
and sandy moulin purwanda okay
so let's do another queen scan but then
since we're in a queen's gambit kind of
mood
okay so he goes e6 now this gives us a
choice
and hmm
obviously another thousand bits sexy car
what i think crazy the choices between
playing e4
transposing into the french and playing
c4 and keeping the spirit of
1d4 but let's go e4 and transpose into a
french because i feel like
he might have not intended that thank
you cj storm for the tier two
now yes
now one of the things that i wanted to
tackle
in this speed run is a question of how
to play in closed positions because that
is a very daunting topic for a lot of
players
and it's not an easy topic to talk about
but
let's play the advanced french which is
the og closed position okay knight c6 is
already a mistake
knight c6 is already a mistake
conceptually though it's a positional
mistake because
as we know this creates a pawn chain
pawn chains need to be attacked
particularly ones that give you a space
advantage
so that's where the move c5 comes from
by playing knight c6 he's committing
examples he's committing a similar
mistake
to to this guy when when he played
knight c3 right which is a different
type of mistake he's weakening the pawn
here
here he's blocking the c pawn which is
important for another reason
it's not to defend hispanics to attack
my pawn
now we can just develop unimpeded we can
go knight f3
and we've got a great position okay so
f6 is fine
he attacks the base of the pawn chain
rather than sorry the tip of the pawn
chain rather than the base
which is not a horrible idea but
definitely
not as good as playing c5 so
the same principle applies here as in
two games ago we had
this position right he played knight f6
and
i feel like there's a tendency here to
panic and to assume ah you know i have
to do something about these threats
it's the same kind of mentality here we
need to figure out whether he's actually
threatening
anything so
hey ellen and and the answer to that if
you actually ask yourself that question
and it's not a rhetorical question is is
no because this pawn is protected twice
and it's attacked twice which means we
don't need to do anything with it we
don't even need to protect it
as a matter of fact if he takes on e5
he's going to make even more weaknesses
on his king side and that's going to
help
us five bucks from jetta thank you
i'll answer that after the game so what
should we do in this position that was a
long-winded explanation
what should we do in this in this
position we should just develop as if
nothing had happened what should we
develop here well
this bishop seems like a good piece to
develop we can pin the knight
but i would prefer for this bishop to
participate in a potential attack
against his king
so what am i saying here yeah bishop d3
i'll talk about why pinning the knight
is not such a good idea after the game
it's not a terrible idea
but he would have just played bishop d7
and unpinned
the knight and then our bishop would
have been essentially unemployed and
also susceptible to a certain tactic
okay but
why not five yeah so he takes
and so do we and now look at his
king and look at you know there's no
pawn here we've got these kinds of moves
we've got
these kinds of ideas but before we apply
any of them let's patiently castle to
make sure that our king doesn't cause us
any problems
and you know i know that these positions
are
mysterious to a lot of people i won't be
able to explain everything
but hopefully i'm demystifying certain
things okay
come fly down here to miami i'd love to
sexyco when i'm in charlotte i'm pretty
close thousand bits thank you
okay um so what should we do
now there's a couple of ways to approach
this position
bishop g5 is a very tempting developing
move but it doesn't do as much
as i think some people realize because
he just moves his queen over to f7
and that bishop is sort of staring into
thin air right and it's actually kind of
helping him get his night out to e7 i
hope that makes sense
the fact that his queen is on e7 is a
blessing for us because it's blocking
the knight from coming out to any kind
of civilized square
so what i'm getting at here is that we
actually
have the potential to start attacking
him but in order to start attacking him
it would be a good idea to open up the
center
so what move am i hinting at here and
he's disconnected here unfortunately
okay reconnected boom i think c4 is the
classy move
so he's got all these structural
weaknesses in his position
and when i see these words like
structural weaknesses or development
advantage
you should be associating that with
opening up the center
by opening up the center you're going to
ease
you're going to make it easier for
yourself
to not only attack his king but to
access all of these weak squares
this is a great example of this now
the move d4 um what is the drawback of
this move it weakens the e4 square what
do we want on e4
this is a great maneuver but before we
do that let's go a3
threatening to trap his bishop with b4
and c5 this also covers the b4 square
so that he won't have any knight before
shenanigans i noticed somebody said that
yeah
let's cover that square his best move
would be a5
and then we're gonna swing this knight
around to this beautiful and juicy
central square
i mean i hope my play makes sense um
okay he doesn't prevent see and this is
the good thing about playing like this
is it's like we
circumvent the need to even play
position let me just win his piece
yeah this is basically winning
so it takes takes
and we're up a piece okay now there's no
need for us to give this bishop away
we we can and and there's many things
that we can do in a position like this
many many things
we can simply take his pawn but
some of you guys are noticing the
relationship between the queen and the
knight they're on the same diagonal
we have a dark squared bishop why don't
we put it on a3
and create even further tension in this
position so c5
now let's simplify the position what
does that mean what is the best way to
simplify
and thank you guys and while we're
simplifying we can also snag another
pawn
yeah so let's take the knight and
obviously we can hit this pawn while
we're at it
because why not we can vacuum this guy
up this also paves the way for a queen
h5 check in the future so
it's conducive to our attacking plans in
fact he's just walked
right into that move so let's play it
queen h5 check why not
thank you the josh c now what should we
do here if you've been doing your puzzle
rush
this move should come with the snap of a
finger
there's free stuff absolutely everywhere
boom
this is like as classic of an idea as it
gets bishop takes g6
check and if he takes he drops not only
the rook but that comes with another pin
so if he takes r knight we take his
and then we're gonna pick off that rook
in the end and that's probably
he should castle here but that doesn't
really help he does
now we're up a row and first thing we
should
we should we should orient ourselves for
a second we should figure out what's
going on
well what's going on is that our night
is hanging some of you guys
might be a little concerned about this
little thing over here but if you break
that down for a second is he actually
threatening any kind of discovered
attack against the queen
you should be concerned about it you
should be obsessed with the health and
safety of your queen
should make sure it's vaccinated first
but is he actually threatening any kind
of dangerous discovery no
if he plays 97 we just move the queen we
have plenty of squares
so we don't even need to move the screen
from a chain because it's actually doing
a great job
of protecting the e5 bottle we need to
move is this knight on d4
where should we move it we've got a lot
of good squares we can move it to b5
and uh try to get it to d6 but then he
can take it
but where else can we move it what would
be the classy square
the classy square would be
where so not
knight f3 but knight b3 attacking the
queen
play with tempo when you can and
bonus points if you suck queen takes c4
boom boom
rook c1 the knight defense that square
now you might be looking at this and
saying how should how am i supposed to
see this well
that's where solving puzzles and
tactical awareness comes in i can't
tell you a formula for seeing everything
there are some things that you just sort
of have to instinctually
see and that means that's something
which can be developed through solving
and through reading okay so c5 is a good
move but we don't need to play it
instead of c5 thank you for the three
bucks
what should we do what else can we
suggest what other ideas do you guys
have
there's something we haven't completed
yet there's something we haven't
completed yet
and that is our development until we
complete our development i don't even
want to think about these moves
yes 92 have the restraint
to complete your development in these
kinds of positions it's going to make
your job a lot easier
thank you for the 6 000 sexy car
well why did you send me a dm sexy car
we'll coordinate
i wouldn't i wouldn't rule it out for
sure thank you uh tomfill94
and uh regal for the prime
i wouldn't rule it out sexy car
don't another thousand bits from the
dark knight rises thank you sir
why not move the effort to protect the
knight i'll explain it fantastic
question let me write this down
dark knight's question well on the topic
of your question
um we can now
play rook f to d1 and
create the tension against the against
the bishop
okay now we can bring the queen back
because he was he was attacking it
and now we just converge on him and in
general attacking with pieces
is going to be a little bit more
intuitive and safer than attacking with
pawns
so here i can tell that a lot of you are
thinking about c5
but let's say that i forced you to play
with pieces
rather than play with pawns what would
you do eric thank you for the sub
well rookie five blunders the rook but
good thought
that's okay okay so you guys are trying
to play with the rooks but
knights are the pieces that act like
screwdrivers and there's a lot of these
weak squares
great move rook d6 i love that i love
that move i'm going to play rook d6 i
was thinking knight c5
but i love the move rook d6 because it
pins his knight and it prepares the
double rooks and then you're going to
play knight vc5 after all of that is
complete
and that is going to be absolutely
crushing
yeah there's a lot there's a lot of
stuff that goes on in this game so
i hope i'm not being obnoxious
there's a lot to capture here all of
these most people are suggesting are
fine
it's not that i'm claiming this is the
best move i think this is one of the
possible wins one of the many possible
wins
in the position okay we're going to
double rooks
notice how the fact that i completed my
development is making all of this
possible
and it's coming very effortlessly
because we've got so many pieces
available to attack if we had gone head
over heels
before playing with like knight d2 it
would have been a lot harder to actually
complete the attack so so easily
okay all right
i'm not sick i'm just uh tired and we're
going to end after this game
okay this is over let me look at his
position he's totally paralyzed
now we get the knight to c5 we can just
ignore this doesn't matter
take d7
yeah so we have a couple of flashy wins
but
how do we actually bring this to its
conclusion
how do we actually bring this to its
conclusion
so the easiest is to understand that the
rook on d8 is a type 2 undefended piece
if this bishop were to disappear then
queen takes d8 would be crushing so
96 is not the flashiest but it is
fastest win
yeah this is winning thank you surfing
it
yeah rookie 6 is good but rookie 6
doesn't force black into anything this
actually forces black
to probably to resign
queendy directly is not as clear now
queenie directly i actually didn't like
and okay so he goes there we can just
take this
we could have taken over the night
doesn't matter this is winning
yeah this is over over and done with
two rooks up and we're mating him
yeah i'll i'll do the i'll answer the
questions after the game that will end
don't worry
i will we had a great question from the
dark knight rises too
which i wanted to answer okay
good game thank you sandy mulan rwanda
okay so as i explained
c5 is the move we won't delve into the
theory today
but most of you guys already know that
uh the c5 is in ic6 is a conceptual
mistake
now to understand why you need to attack
the base of the pawn chain
you don't need to understand any chess
it's an architectural thing i think
right
if you're playing jenga um
right it's if you have to remove the
base of the tower
it's far likelier that the whole
foundation topples than if you're just
to remove the top
right if you have a stack of books and
let's say those are stack of debratsky
books and
you know you have a stack of books and
you remove
the top book the integrity of the
structure remains alive obviously
i'm deliberating the point here with a
pawn chain it's quite the same thing
if you play c5
and y takes then the pawn on e5 becomes
weak
right and the pawn on c5 becomes weak
everything collapses
if black plays f6 and you take on f6
okay you have a pawn trade but the base
of the pawn chain is not affected
even if black plays f6 and takes as he
did in the game
this doesn't really affect the integrity
of the chain
okay so that's the bottom line here
now the problem when i say these things
is people come back
a week later and they say well daniel i
heard you say this thing i thought it
was very wise
uh and guess what my opponent attacked
the base of the pawn chain and he won
didn't you tell me that this is
innocuous you always have to
you have to take this with a grain of
salt there are plenty of situations when
even the move f6 in the french
is a great move it's often a great move
in the french but
that may be for another reason for
example
um a reason why f6 might be good is to
carve out the d6 square for the bishop
right that could be a legitimate reason
play f6 but you're not actually trying
to
undermine the pawn chain here so take
this with a grain of salt
but very often it's more uh it's just
powerful more powerful to attack the
base of the pawn chain
okay so bishop d3 right
um half takes c5d takes e4 another good
reason to keep this pawn on e5
is to prevent him from developing the
knight to f6 obviously
that's that's sort of self-evident from
the placement of the pawn
okay so bishop c5 castles we need seven
now c4 to open the center
and here it's less about attacking so
wait here
we're attacking the base of the pawn
chain technically why are we doing that
well we're doing that because it's not
that we're trying to destroy the pawn
chain itself
we're trying to carve out these light
squares for the knight particularly and
we're also trying to open up the center
so this move has less to do with
attacking the pawn chain than with
opening up the center
yeah this is a hard move to plan yeah
this is the move that
i think to a lot of people is not
intuitive
why is that i think the reason
has to do with the fact there exists a
very tempting move bishop g5
which as i explained is in my opinion a
lot less powerful than it seems
why because it actually kind of helps
black by repositioning the queen to f7
black
gains the e7 square for the knight so
this actually eases
the develop facilitates the development
for black and
this bishop on g5 as you guys can see
it's it's empty it's not doing much and
also to add insult to injury imagine if
black castles
you would love for a knight to be on g5
right you would love for this kind of
tactic to work now this bishop is
blocking uh that knight from coming to
g5 so it's
actually quite a bad vision so
that's like something that i see kind of
intuitively but
hopefully more people see that now once
you understand that
you begin to understand that you have a
short window of opportunity in which
black has not developed the king side
black has developed the bishop
and in the short window of opportunity
you want to open up the position as much
as possible because
that is the typical prescription for
exploiting a lead in development you
want to open up the center and that's
how you find c4
okay that's one way of thinking about it
so d4 a3
threatening now he should have played a5
of course and then we would have gotten
the knight to e4
and perhaps then we would have played
bishop g5 that's much better idea than
before
five bucks thank you so much appreciate
it uh gm no chance ever and
uh the dark knight rises with a sub
so after this we win the piece now we
had a great question
from the dark knight rises which i
thought was an excellent
excellent question the question was to
paraphrase
why did you not play rook d1 because the
knight is already in a nice central
square right
now here's where i'm going to pull out
the last
sort of substantive piece of advice for
today
when you're evaluating the placement of
a piece most people only consider one
thing
and that is the placement of a piece
relative to the board
the knight is in the center so it's as
good as it can be
what are the other two qualities that
you have to factor in
the first is defendedness so
we have type one undefended pieces and
type two undefended pieces that's all i
mean if a piece is a type two or a type
one and offended piece
it's going to be um less effective most
of the time
than a piece which is defended so if you
repositioned
this e pawn to e3 then this knight
would have been a fully defended piece
but
on d4 it's a type 2 undefended piece
it's defended by only one other piece
this immediately creates the possibility
for what kind of a tactic and you should
see this tactic because you also notice
that the rook on d1 is fully undefended
so
what kind of unpleasant move might black
have and this move isn't that good here
but in general
what sort of move might black have
deflection right
so bishop c6 for example yeah and then
the knight is attacked
that's unpleasant yeah bishop a4
although here you can play rook takes a4
but i'm making a more general point here
the third thing that you have to factor
in is roll
and what i mean by that is that a piece
can be fully centralized
it can be smack dab in the middle of the
board and it can be doing
absolutely nothing now you could also
have a piece on the side of the board
and that piece is it seems like the
worst piece in the world it's not
protecting any squares
or it's it's controlling like three
squares and yet that is the most
effective
most powerful piece in the world you
could have both scenarios
because although controlling more
squares
increases the likelihood that a piece is
going to be well placed
that does not in and of itself uh
determine
whether a piece is well placed if that
makes it so you have to factor in all
three things
when you're evaluating peace placement
that's what makes that concept art if
peace placement was only about
where on the board a piece is placed it
would be very easy
but there's other things that must be
factored in and here
although the knight is in the center
it's undefended and it's not really
doing anything
one could argue that it's pressuring the
pawn but this pawn is well defended by
the bishop
sorry to belabor the point but i just
wanted to spit that one out
so knight b3 this knight is
defended it's hard to attack and it can
potentially go to c5 so it's got a much
better
uh role and it actually wins us the game
that same night is
precisely the night that wins us the
game
so that knight goes to c5
so in order of importance
you should use uh the centrality of
pieces as
a shortcut like if if you're
decentralizing a piece if you're putting
the knight on the rim
then that should raise your alarm bells
but
you sh you shouldn't not do it just
because the night is on the rim
if there's a good reason to put the
knight on the rim
then that should supersede the fact that
it's not controlling squares and i will
end
with an example that i have hunted down
just now
that comes from an old chess.com article
that i had
so here is a good example hopefully this
will clarify things
hopefully this will clarify things and
then we will end
okay this applies to all pieces but
particularly tonight's of course
of course particularly tonight's you
know that's that's really what i'm
focusing on here
so we will end with this ribley against
larson
now you guys know who larson is of
course ripley hungarian grandmaster
we've got a very closed position
and this may seem like a dead draw but
in fact white is better
and the reason white is better is
because black's got all of these very
weak squares in his position
and white can exploit those weak squares
but only if he plays very accurately and
in this position what's up man
white found a brilliant idea
and this idea involves a maneuver what
is he maneuvering into what square now a
lot of you guys are looking at this move
but black can simply go f6 and block the
pin
unfortunately that is not effective
thank you pat's or machine
what did white do in this position
yeah men found it so ribley asks himself
well what are the weak squares in
black's position
and he identifies this square look at
this amazing juicy square on b5
well what can we put on that square well
how about a knight well how can we do it
boom knight a1 knight c2
now what larson does is he brings his
knight to c7
in order to control b5 and
you get this insane and very interesting
relationship between the knights
where white's knight is holding all of
the power
because black's knight is tied down to
the square even though black's knight is
closer to the center technically
white's knight is the one holding all of
the power here because the moment
the blacks knight leaves c7 white's
knight is going to jump to b5 and
eventually
eventually it takes him a long time long
long time
but eventually that night um
b5 becomes green eventually 20 moves
later than it gets to b5
and uh this is precisely the night that
wins him the game
because that knight comes into c7 it's a
brilliant game
and larson ribley uses that knight to
win an exchange
so this is a good example of a knight
being on the rim
and the knight having a very much
full-fledged role on the room
so white's night is not tied down
white's knight can
leave anytime it wants to and black's
knight will have no prospects
so i wrote an article several years back
called
knights on the rim are amazing i invite
you to take a look at that one
if you want more about this and you want
this game annotated
but for now i'm going to write an
article called daniel nerinisky is going
to sleep
because this has been a long stream it's
been an exhausting one and it has been
an amazing one thank you the dark knight
rises for a thousand bits
[Music]